[Musique]
lundi 5 février bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur tv78 voici les titres de
l'actualité l'Île-de-France reprend la
gestion de l'île- de loisirs de 50 ans
en yine la présidente de la région
Valérie PCR a dévoilé aujourd'hui son
plan pour je cite sauver le site elle
remet en cause également le choix du
conseil départemental de se désengager
du Syndicat de Gestion de la base c'est
une obligation depuis le 1er janvier les
collectivités doivent apporter à leurs
habitants une solution pour trier leurs
biodéchets une habitude déjà bien ancrée
à 50 ans en yeline ou des compostur
individuels seront sont distribués aux
habitants depuis 2019 reportage de
grandes ambitions pour 2024 le Vélo Club
d'élancours 50 an neling Team vouser
vient de présenter son équipe féminine
pour cette saison Coupe de France top 5
jeux olympiques et paralympiques les
objectifs sont nombreux et prestigieux
pour l'équipe cycliste et puis un match
de basket à l'ambiance survolté des
concours de dunk et des shows de
cheerleaders non vous n'êtes pas sur un
campus américain mais bien à versaill
Ginette contre hoch c'est ce jeudi au
gymnase montburon et les élèves de prépa
des lycées saint-jun VIè et HOG vont
s'affronter pour la 18e fois saint-jn
vieve mène 15 à 2 au bilan des
confrontation on en parle dans les
invités du 78 en 2è partie d'émission et
je suis accompagné de Michel elmidoro
pour cette édition bonsoir Michel vous
allez nous parler dans un instant des
résultats sport ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité sportive du weekend quel est
le programme on parlera notamment de la
victoire de Versailles en National ça
sera du football on parlera également
football avec la coupe gambardellaa et
on reviendra également sur la D1 de
districts ça sera aussi du football il
faudra aimer le football dans cette
émition football ce sera tout à l'heure
dans il y aura la course à pied aussi
avec le cross de la sablère qui s'est
tenu ce weekend à virofl av on va faire
avec vous le point sur les informations
du jour dans les
evelines
et on commence avec ce geste qui a
permis sans doute de sauver la vie de
nombreuses personnes celui donc de la
personne qui a maîtrisé l'auteur de
l'attaque au couteau samedi à la gare de
Lyon il s'agit d'un agent de sécurité
embauché par une entreprise ivelinoise
oui grégoryi celui qui a réussi à
neutraliser et désarmer la saillence et
lui abdahman c cet agent de sécurité de
45 ans est employé par la société ESP
sécurité basée à montinil bretonux
expert en port de combat et vigile
depuis 20 ans il fait partie des Tasque
forces mobilisées dans les grandes gares
du pays l'agent de sécurité est
aujourd'hui rentré chez lui après un
court passage à l'hôpital suite à cette
attaque trois personnes ont été blessées
dont une gravement l'assaillant quant à
lui a été interpellé puis placé en garde
à vue ce dimanche j'en parlais dans les
titres après plusieurs mois
d'incertitude on en sait plus sur la
gestion de l'île de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yveline c'est exacte Grégory Valérie PCR
la présidente de la région île-de-fance
annoncé auprès de nos confrères du
Parisien en reprendre la gestion au
total 4 millions d'euros seront investis
chaque année par la région pour assurer
le fonctionnement de l'île des loisirs
pour Rael jusqu'en décembre 2023 la
région Île-de-France était simplement
chargée des investissements de la base
tandis que le département et
l'agglomération de 50 ans en liveline se
partager les frais de fonctionnement les
deux collectivités se sont retirées du
Syndicat de Gestion de la base dans
l'interview accordé aux Parisiens la
présidente de la région n'a pas hésité à
pointer du doigt le
département et donc je site Valérie pcrè
voilà en arrêtant de financer l'île le
département a tourné le dos à la
vocation sociale supposée être la sienne
quand on joue en équipe on est solidaire
et on ne marque pas contre son camp
l'équipe de direction a été incapable de
gérer correctement cette île alors que
la région elle a investi plus de 6
millions d'euros depuis 2016 voici les
mots rapportés par Le Parisien de
Valérie PCR et du côté du département
des imines selon nos informations aucune
réaction à chaud ne sera faite par
rapport à la mise en cause de la
présidente du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France l'entourage de Pierre
Bédier nous fait çavoir sa voir que la
position du département est totalement
assumée il précise que l'institution
départementale est favorable au maintien
de l'activité de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin niiveline alors justement
toujours concernant Valéri pcret ce
lundi matin le maire de Guy encours
François Morton tenait une conférence de
presse pour alerter sur les mesures
antig-etto voulues par la présidente de
région tout à fait Grégory pour Rael en
mars 2022 la région Île-de France a
lancé la révision de son schéma
directeur environnemental pour décider
de l'aménagement du territoire d'ici à
2040 en septembre 2023 la présidente de
la région Valérie pcrè décidé d'y
inclure une clause antig-etto visant à
freiner la production de logements
sociaux dans les communes en don en
comptant au moins 30 % l'objectif est
selon elle de freiner je cite le
communautarisme et l'islamisme une
aberration pour François Morton dont la
commune directement concernée compte 50
% de logements sociaux on écoute sa
réaction au micro de Julien Leroi
l'application de cette clause antig-etto
aurait comme effet immédiat une baisse
de production de logements sociaux de 21
% et donc elle nous interdirait à terme
de continuer à construire du logement
social là où 70 % des Franciliens ils
sont éligibl qu'on nous fasse confiance
nous connaissons nos villes nous savons
effectivement comment les les peupler
comment apporter le service public qui
va avec malgré les baisses drastiques de
dotation moi je crois qu'il ne faut pas
avoir peur voilà il faut permettre à
chacun de pouvoir se loger dignement on
termine avec une information sportive 5
mois avant le début des Jeux Olympiques
le Stadium de BMX reace on le rappelle
situé juste à côté du Vélodrome national
de 50 ans enine va être remodelé
l'objectif à respecter l'équité avec les
futures nations et ne pas avantager la
nation haute lors des épreuves car vous
le savez l'équipe de France utilise
quotidiennement cette piste alors
pendant 4 semaines les équipes de la
solidéo la société de livraison des
ouvrages olympiques vont réaménager la
piste spécialement pour les jeux sa
longueur restera la même mais deux
tribunes temporaires seront aménager
pour accueillir jusqu'à 3000 spectateurs
les tests opérationnels sont prévus du 5
au 7 avril 2024 merci Michel et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les evelines
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
news apporter aux habitants une sol une
solution pour trier leur biodéchet c'est
une obligation pour les collectivités
depuis le 1er janvier dernier à 50 an
eline l'agglomération propose des
séances de distribution de composteurs
individuels il y a quelques jours par
exemple une vingtaine de participants a
pu profiter de conseil d'experts avant
de repartir avec un précieux kit le
reportage de Julien Leroi ça va prendre
peut-être un peu plus de temps mais il y
a pas que les bactéries aussi qui
viennent décomposer valoriser ses restes
alimentaires un geste pour la planète
accompagné durant 1 heure par Noémi
conseillère prévention déchets une
vingtaine d'habitants ont appris les
bonnes pratiques avant de récupérer leur
composteur individuel depuis 2019
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline les remet dans le cadre du Plan
compostage il vise à proposer une
solution de tri à la source pour les
biodéchets à chaque foyer une obligation
pour les collectivités territoriales
depuis le 1er janvier
2024 on a toujours tendance à dire
aujourd'hui que finalement le déchet
qu'on ne produit pas c'est le meilleur
déchet bah le plan compostage c'est un
des meilleurs exemples c'est-à-dire
qu'on va détourner ce flux de biodéchet
plus tress cible et compostable avant
même que ça devienne un déchet puisqu'on
va l'orienter vers le le bac à compost
c'est important pour l'environnement
d'abord parce que il y a moins à
collecter ensuite ça veut dire que on va
moins incinérer puisque nous aujourd'hui
n nos déchets sont incinérés au centre
de traitement du du sidomp des questions
qui intéressent les habitants depuis ce
début d'année l'agglomération est passée
de une à deux distributions par semaine
et plus chure de légumes coquis d'œuf ou
marre de café chaque Français génère 83
kg de biodéchets par an un enjeu
important car cela représente environ un
tiers de nos déchets non triés
généralement les appréhensions qu'on va
avoir c'est tout d'abord les rongeurs le
fait d'attirer les rongeurs mais comme
on dit généralement les rongeurs sont
déjà là avant que le composteur arrive
et sinon ce qui revient très
généralement ce sont tout ce qui est
autour des agrumes et des oignons ce
myth qui dit enfin qui quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui perdure sur le
fait qu'on ne peut pas composter cette
matière organique alors que si il y a il
y a aucun souci ça m'a confirmé pas mal
d'informations que j'avais déjà et ça me
permet surtout de me dire on est on a
derrière nous une équipe qui qui a
l'habitude de recevoir toutes les
questions possibles auxquelles nous on
sera confronté et donc oui j'ai
confiance intéressant de voir qu'il y a
du monde aussi qui s'intéresse à ce
sujet et tous ensemble on va
certainement réussir à réduire la
collecte des déchets compter 25 € pour
un composteur 300 L et 30 € pour un 570
l pour en profiter il faut habiter en
pavillon et posséder une carte déchet
depuis 2019 plus de 4000 composteurs
individuels ont été distribués à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline l'objectif
serait d'équipé 12000 logements soit 20
% défouyés à l'horizon 2030 pour le
collectif l'agglomération compte une
trentaine de points de compostage
partager on ouvre la page des actualités
sportives dans le
[Musique]
78 avec Michel el mid toujours installé
en plateau et on commence
pars on très bien on est très très bien
alors pour le lancement de la saison le
Vélo Club est en cours à 50 ans Livine
team vous présenter son équipe féminine
2024 l'objectif cette année les manches
de Coupe de France un top 5 en en
National 2 et pour certaines d'entre
elles les Jeux Olympiques un reportage
de Gabriel Gontier et Mathilde Francou
une saison avec de grandes ambitions le
Vélo Club et l'encour Saint-Quentin en
Yveline présenté ce weekend sa type
vousert composé de 16 filles dont 12
recrue le collectif de National 2
pourrait bien faire briller la France
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
cette année est bien parce qu'on a
l'aralallemand qui a un niveau
international on a 4 jeunes filles qui
ont un niveau national et d'autres
niveau régional mais si ça peut bien se
passer je pense un sentiment que partage
le Parin de l'équipe et champion du
monde 2019 Quentin la Fargue ça a l'air
d'être une belle équipe en tout cas
beaucoup d'ambitions qui s'est staffé
qui a l'air de plus en plus
professionnel cette année l'année 1
commence avec beaucoup d'ambition dans
le collectif avec en tête d'affiche
voilà la RAL allemand qui a qui a montré
de belles choses au niveau national sur
les championnats de France piste et
cetera qui fera j'imagine un peu office
de leader qui va essayer de fédérer un
peu tout le monde pour aller chercher
des beaux résultats donc une belle
équipe un beau collectif et et voilà je
leur souhaite tout le meilleur pour
cette année l'objectif de la saison
atteindre le top 5 du classement avec en
ligne de mirire la Nationale 1 parmi les
leaders de l'équipe pour accéder au haut
niveau la versaillaise laralallemand
tout juste 19 ans qui espère bien voir
prier l'équipe cette année moi je
connais l'équipe et je sais que tout va
bien se passer on espère déjà réussir à
monter plus haut que l'année dernière
avec les problèmes qu'on a eu mais je
pense performer déjà sur les coupes de
France faire des places parce que c'est
dans les 20 premières qu'on peut avoir
des des points donc figurer dans les 20
premières places dans les Coupe de
France prochain rendez-vous la première
épreuve de Coupe de France le 24 mars en
Bretagne avec les boucles gegonaises et
pour les PISTAR d'un enjeu de taille à
172 jours des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques certaines ont encore des
chances de décrocher une place pour les
jeux un rendez-vous à domicile au
Vélodrome national de C ans en IBL
et on continue par du football avec le
championnat national versaill se reprend
en National les joueurs de la cité
royale se sont imposés à 2 à1 sur la
pelouse de rouan le buteur les buteurs
côté versaillais Chris Kevin NADJE et
media à balouge une victoire qui fait du
bien aux ivelinois il se retrouve à la
11e place du classement avec un bilan de
6 victoires 6 Nules et 7 défaites depuis
le début de la saison ils ne sont qu'à C
petits points de la 4e place prochain
match vendredi prochain à domicile
contre leement toujours en football mais
chez les jeunes ont joué les 16e de
finale de la Coupe G là deux équipes
ivinoises étaient concernées par ce tour
les U19 du FC Mantois se sont imposé 1
à0 sur la pelouse du Havre à domicile
une très belle performance des joueurs
du nord du département dans l'autre
rencontre le match ivri versaill n'a pas
pu aller à son terme le match a été
arrêté alors que les Versaillais mené 2
à0 la raison l'arbitre a arrêté le match
car il a été pris pour cible les
Versaillais devraient sans doute gagner
le match sur tapis vert la commission de
discipline de la Fédération française de
football se saisira du dossier dans les
prochaines heures encore du football
mais cette fois-ci dans le championnat
de D1 district oui en football ont joué
ce weekend la 12e journée du championnat
de D1 de district l'équipe 2 d'ARD cours
s'est imposé à 2 à0 sur le terrain de
moropa une défaite qui peut être lourde
de conséquen pour les morpasiens pour la
suite du championnat le résumé du
match c'était le match de la peur ce
dimanche 4 février au stade du Bout clos
l'équipe locale de moropa recevait
hardardric cour une autre équipe en
difficulté dans le championnat de D1 de
district en première période malgré une
légère domination des morpasiens la
partie Est tchée et le score n'évoluera
pas le score à la pause 0 à0 nous on
avait un bloc bas eu il poussaient un
peu sur nous on avait de quoi faire la
différence en première mi-temps mais
mais vu qu'on partait de très loin
c'était assez compliqué on é un peu trop
bas on avait le ballon mais cétait une
possession assez stérile on on a manqué
de mouvement devant et on sait pas si
créé d'occasion en seconde période le
rythme est plus rapide et c'est un
penalty qui va débloquer la situation le
joueur d'Ardour tremble pas 1-0 morpa
tente de réagir mais ce sont finalement
les joueurs du nord du département des
ivines qui font le break 2 à0 ce sera le
score
final on c'est un peu plus libéré parce
que je pense que aussi l'équipe adverse
voulait pousser pour marquer et ben on a
suit faire la différence on a obtenu un
penalty et puis ensuite on a marqué
derrière dans la foulée ils ont mis plus
d'impact plus de densité au milieu de
terrain
et ils ont su concrétiser les actions
qui qu'ils ont eu le très peu
d'occasions qu'ils ont eu ils les ont
marqué c'est le football hein c'est
celui qui marque le plus de buts qui
gagne et c'est comme ça au classement
ardrico respire et se retrouve à la 8e
place du championnat de son côté moropa
est avant-dernier après 12 matchs
disputés le club qui est descendu
l'année dernière de R3 espère ne pas
connaître une deuxième descente
consécutive une dernière je suis déjà
descendu avec la avec la R3 là
redescendre
j'avoue non non j'ai pas envie hein j'ai
qui personne n envie de descendre là on
va tout tout faire pour essayer de de
Mir le club oh bien les deux équipes
joueront dès ce dimanche 11 février
ardrico recevra les Mureaux et morepa se
déplacera sur la pelouse de confland
2 et de la course à pied à présent
Michel ce dimanche était programmé le
cross de la sablère six cours était au
programme de cette 42e édition à
virireoflet le cross court de 6 km a été
gagné par le cadet Antoine MiTo a noté
l'excellente performance d' d'Alan
Brachet de l'USM viroflet qui termine 2e
le 11 km à quant à lui était remporté
par le Kenan Cornélius kangongo ancien
vice-champion d'Afrique le cross de
cross country au total 1324 sportifs ont
participer à cette édition un record et
on termine avec du tennis ce weekend au
comité de tennis de feroll la France a
remporté la Winter Cup 2024 des moins de
16 ans féminines les Français se sont
imposés en finale 2-1 face à la Turquie
grâce à une victoire en double l'Italie
complète le podium les Italiens ont
remporté la 3oè place face à la Croatie
le comité de tennis de Foll devrait
accueillir à nouveau cette compétition
internationale l'année prochaine bravo à
nos françaises qui ont remporté cette
édition merci Michel on va continuer de
parler sport justement dans les invités
du Ctude mais juste avant coup d'œil aux
prévisions météo de
demain des conditions similaires à
aujourd'hui demain matin le ciel sera
couvert dans les ivelines il fera 9
degrés dans le nord du département 8
degr sur le reste du territoire pas ou
peu d'évolution dans l'après-midi où ce
sera toujours nuageux le thermomètre
grimpe légèrement compté en moyenne de
11 à 12 degrés dans les ivelines et ce
mardi 6 février nous fêterons les
gastons tout de suite les invités du
[Musique]
78 un duel vieux de 18 ans les élèves de
prépa de deux lycées versaillais qui se
font face d'un côté saintjn viev dit
Ginette de l'autre h pour enflammer la
soirée une ambiance survoltée et des
shows dignes de campus américains
universitaire le match ginetoche c'est
ce jeudi soir au gymnase montburon à
Versailles alors pour en parler en
plateau plusieurs invités nous ont
rejoint déjà les capitaines des deux
équipes alors sur la gauche il y a Ilan
nengsu bonsoir bonsoir et Gabi
larenduchche bonsoir petit tour de table
déjà avec vous comment vous vous sentez
à quelques jours de ce match Ilan bien
bien forcément stressé parce que bon il
y a il y a l'événement qui a de
l'ampleur et qu'il arrive à grand pas
mais bon audelà de ça on a tous très
hâte que ce soit pour les élèves ou pour
les joueurs euh les cheaders aussi
s'entraînent depuis longtemps et ont
hâte de faire l'événement donc plus
d'impatience que de l'appréhension il a
capitaine de he Gaby gitaine de Ginette
et côté Ginette comment on se sentelques
j du match on sent assez bien côté
Ginette on se sent bien dansre basket on
s'est entraîné dur depuis le début de
l'année donc on sent prêt à attaquer le
match de jeudi alors l'homme qui est
derrière cette organisation ce match
Ginat c'est vous François Lamand bonsoir
et donc organisateur de de ce match qui
donc on le dit un 18e édition pour cet
événement vous vous sentez comment vous
aussi avant d'aborder cette 18e édition
je me sens un peu
tendu parce que organiser c'est pas
toujours simple donc une forme de
tension qui ces dernières semaines qui
monte qui monte qui monte donc j'attends
que l'événement arrive rapidement parce
que voilà mais c'est positif tous les
signaux sont au vert vous allez réussir
à dormir quand même oui je me lève très
tôt très tôt en ce moment non non tout
tout se passe très bien belle
organisation alors pour se faire
justement une idée de ce qu'est Ginette
Hoche une idée de l'ambiance sur PL je
vous propose qu'on regarde cet extrait
c'était l'édition de l'année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu
[Musique]
on l'a compris Ginette h c'est plus
qu'un match de basket c'est aussi toute
une ambiance autour ça vous fait quoi de
jouer devant 1000 personnes on précise
que c'est pas votre première vous avez
participer à l'édition de l'année
dernière qui avait été remporté par par
junette ça vous fait quoi de jouer
devant un public aussi survoleté Ilan
c'est toujours très particulier moi vu
je redouble il y a 2 ans déjà je l'avais
fait et même l'année dernière en l'ayant
déjà fait l'anne avant du coup ça m'a
fait le même choc qu' est entr sur le
terrain en voyant les tout le public
autour de moi donc forcément c'est c'est
très particulier et quand on joue
particulièrement ça se ressent mais
au-delà de ça quand on prend un peu de
recul sur la chose on se dit que c'est
vraiment une expérience particulière et
qu'on est heureux de la vivre au moins
une fois dans sa vie à force sur GAB il
y a aussi un peu de chambrage c'est
c'estette bonne guerre aussi autour de
ce rendez-vous il y a pas trop de stress
à jouer devant un public qui parfois
peut vous faire des petites blagues non
ça va en vrai la pression non non ça
va ça reste gentil quand même oui oui
c'est ça ça reste gentil on sait que des
deux côtés sa chambre et dans tous les
cas ça nous pousse à être un peu
meilleur cette cette pression que peut
mettre alors c'est un match pas comme
les autres on l'a dit François qui
attire aussi les regs il y a l'ex
basketteur Fred Weiss un médaillé
d'argent Joo avec la France en 2000 qui
accompagne l'événement depuis plusieurs
années les caméra de la presse nationale
aussi se presse justement sur sur cet
événement on a l'impression que c'est un
événement qui qui gagne chaque année en
popularité vous avez aussi ce ce
ressenti oui il y a eu un emballement
depuis quelques années c'est
devenu oui couru de partout parce que ça
répond peut-être à à des aspirations à
des besoins de amuser de voir que des
jeunes peuvent faire une soirée réussie
et montée par eux parce que il y a une
organisation des étudiants énormes qu'il
faut féliciter et puis ça répond à ouais
à du sens se retrouver partager des
diversités pas que du sport une belle
fête voilà surtout avec des des
étudiants qui travaillent énormément il
faut le dire ils sont dans une année oui
enfin dans des années de prépa qui
peuvent être stressantes justement ça ça
permet d'pporter petit touche de dans
exactement exactement et
ouais vivre quoi vivre un soir avant les
concours c'est super important je crois
voilà ça été monté comme ça puis on na
pas tout contrôlé maîtrisé et je pense
qu'on est à maturité dans l'événement je
je crois Mel parce que je je le précise
il travaillent tout pendant l'événement
ils font pas que l'événement pendant
l'année ils travaillent très dur pendant
à côté de l'événement vous
confirmez il le confirme alors côté
sportif Ginette de domine largement le
bilan des confrontations 15 à 2 la
dernière victoire de H Ilan ça remonte à
2022 j'imagine vous avez à cœur
d'essayer d'enrayer la machine Ginette
cette année forcément forcément ça
ferait plaisir de gagner d'autant que on
est on est poussé non seulement par
notre envie personnel mais aussi par
tout le public de H qui est derrière
nous et qui vient pour nous pour nous
voir gagner au final donc oui très hâte
de jouer le match et de montrer que bon
ça boêre 15-2 pour l'instant ça peut
monter à 153 très facilement voir plus
pas trop d'excès de confiance du côté de
Ginette comment vous l'abordez ce match
bon on c'est ce qu'on a à faire on va
aller pousser jusqu'au 162 on a tous les
ultras qui pousse derrière nous et qui
nous encourage vraiment dur et donc on
va essayer d'aller chercher cette
victoire comment ça se prépare justement
une rencontre une telle rencontre est-ce
que vous êtes satisfait aussi des de vos
coéquipiers cette année de de l'équipe
oui c'est cette année on a eu quelques
victoires donc en sport universitaire ça
nous a mis en confiance ça nous a mis en
jambe et là euh ouais vraiment on sent
bien euh on a trouvé une vraie alchimie
de groupe on arrive à à bien tout jouer
ensemble et tout donc on sent bien pour
le match et du côté de hoch pareil je
pense que insister sur l'alchimie du
groupe c'est important comme comme G en
parlait parce que c'est un événement qui
justement parce qu'il est rare forge
vraiment et c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on vit qu'on vit souvent donc quand
on le vit en groupe de de 10 15
personnes ça crée des gens très forts et
je pense que la préparation c'est aussi
beaucoup de ça quoi beaucoup
créer une confiance et une habitude de
jeu et la préparation psychologique à
l'ampleur de l'événement et à ce qu'on
vit sur le terrain alors on l'a dit
Ginette c'est pas qu'un match de basket
c'est toute une ambiance tout un un show
les années précédentes François il eu
des performances musicales des shows de
cheer leaders des concours de Dung
démonstrations de danse de freestyle
foot plein de choses au programme c'est
quoi justement le programme de cette
année qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour ce
Ginet c'est autre chose c'est toujours
différent il faut toujours
changer s'habitue jamais à ce qu'on
avait ça a évolué cette année il y aura
plus de champs je crois voilà je veux
pas trop en dire mais il y aura plus de
chance sur tou de surprise toujours
quelques invités originaux quelques
nouveautés après foncièrement ça ça ça
ressemblera mais il suffit de quelques
petites choses pour que pour que le
cocktail soit pas le même on va terminer
avec un petit pronostic ou vous préférez
pas vous vous prononcer j'imagine
victoire de Ha et victoire de pour les
deux capitaines un petit pronostic cette
année François une super soirée une
super soirée c'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite pour pour ce match Ginette ho
qui a donc lieu je le rappelle ce jeudi
soir au gymnase montbouron de Versailles
messieurs alors ça c'est protocolaire on
va vous demander de vous serrer la main
ou voilà pour la fin de cette édition
parce que voilà c'est un match qui doit
être bien sûr dans une ambiance
survoltée sous le signe du du fairplay
mais en tout cas on vous souhaite une
belle rencontre et merci à tous les
trois d'être venus en parlant en plateau
on va revenir dessus la semaine
prochaine oui oui évidemment oui oui on
y sera jeudi soir et on fera un gros
reportage comme d'habitude et on verra
qui le meilleur qui va gagner à la fin
un bon g merci encore d'avoir été avec
nous merci également à Michel de m'avoir
accompagné sur cette édition qui touche
à sa fin on se retrouve dès demain pour
une nouvelle édition du 78 sur tv78 très
belle
[Musique]
soirée